So, broadly, as you and your team are thinking about what to put in the next 3,
4, 5 generations of CUDA, you know, what's foremost in your mind?
What are the sort of characteristics that you're thinking about to pick design features
that are going to move CUDA forward?
>>I'm really focused right now on the heterogeneity problem, that is,
I've got this system where I've got processors which are good at one thing,
serial processing, a processor which is good at another thing, parallel processing.
They're 2 separate processors, and they live with their own separate execution spaces
and memory and hardware and all that kind of thing,
and bridging that gap to make it easier for the programmer to reason about what he wants to do
and to express what he wants without having to fight the system.
That's really where I think that the biggest advances need to be made.
So I'm putting, I'm spending a lot of time thinking about memory models, for example,
making life easier for people who, you know, you might not always know what memory you need to move,
or you might find it inconvenient to figure out how do I move data while I'm computing on something else.
All of those types of things that you have to think about in heterogeneous system.
Anything I can do, and I am really not sure what that is yet, I am still working on it though.
I really see the direction such that whatever we can do to make it that easier
will make the system easier to program, and I think inevitably in the future there is a place where
you've got specialist processors working on the task for which they are ideally suited,
because that gives you the best performance for the power that you've got,
the best performance for the silicone that you've put in there, it probably will solve the problem faster.
You know if you got a massively parallel processor, do your parallel work on it,
but it now means you've got this space where the programmer's no longer thinking about one type of program,
he has to think about 2 or 3 or 4 or however many disparate things he's got.
And you know, I've not yet seen a great solution to this. But, you know, we're working towards trying to find one.